what's up everybody it's your boy Travis
H we back here with 12 talks you know
how we get it's a Monday at 5:00
Mountain Time 7:00 eastern time yeah I
know what time it is turn to get right
into the video right right into it the
video how y'all Monday going y Monday
going good everybody doing yeah your boy
got a fresh cut new hair dud yeah we
know myay dubs yes s
SK no
Monday how I'm feeling I'm good new
headphones yeah new
headphones no more wires bro no more
wires we don't do wires no
more uh thoughts on Jordan Travis just
prayers for that dude man prayers for
our brother it's crazy he just doing
normal football things and end up being
like that I remember me breaking my
ankle was not fun it's hard it's a long
journey just a long super long can't do
anything for a minute just something
that wasn't in the plan but it happened
so just got to bounce back be
ready all right we starting
with yeah we starting with my touchdown
today had touchdown last Friday it's
been a long
week
yeah know I got M little touchdown but
it still don't matter because we lost I
just be want to
win I just want to win
man that's all I want to do yeah prayers
for JT man prayers for Jordan Travis you
know how they
get's play here on here just me playing
defense cover to caught him and I just
took him to the cooler get like Blind
Side try to take him back to the bus you
know how it is
man you know he did some little extra
stuff P my helmet off but it's all good
it's football at the end of the day go
outad there and just
play another loss for the squad at the
season come to an end yeah tough loss
tried to do what I had to do man I lost
my quarterback so really help us it
didn't help us at all had no quarterback
so so we have a quarterback we would
have had our quarterback would have been
different but no quarterback and we just
play like hot Gage that's all it
was oh yeah coach prom talks about how
hard the losing Street been on him talks
about how it affected how affecting me
as
well it's just tough bro I don't like
losing hate losing but hey it comes with
the game you can't win them
all that's all I know I
know all I do is continue to prepare
continue to just go out and play
hard do what I got to do to get better
uh work on my
craft minute know we got to
do yes sir new headphones no I had these
for a minute though but yeah new
headphones yeah yeah we've been
eliminated for both game c uh
considerations you know how that go you
got to win six games we already lost uh
more than six so and we only played 12
games so we definitely not in the
conversation
anymore
but yeah we get we got I get back
soon gotta play better man just gotta
play better gotta score more points in
the next
team yeah press for JT man you know he
gonna bounce back
though who do I got tonight who play
tonight Eagles in the
Chiefs
yeah eag in the Chiefs I don't know who
I got who y'all got didn't I lose last
week keep it solid it's
uh yeah might have said back you know
major comeback you know how that go we
all know how that go you just got to
come back get back
right what we got W
blocks yeah no I am stand true to my
yet can I name an NFL player for edit uh
jayen Ramsey I know he just came back
but Jay ramse been going crazy edit for
jayen Ramsey
bro it reminded you of The Blind Side
yeah I'm trying to tell y take him to
the bus
yeah now it's time for overreaction and
not overreaction let's get right into it
you know how we go you know how it's
played so first
clip hey walk a walk on kickoff team
great world for all the work these guys
put in the scout team yes bro y
understand but they have the hardest job
they got the hardest job they got to
guard the number one players not only
that they got to go back to school right
after they paying to just get beat up on
all week so it's
hard I know how it is walk
on ah f
I seen that
though this is out of a Hollywood script
overreaction no it's
not who going win a Natty I do not
[Music]
know
what is this supposed to be just missed
it uh
obviously I'm
lost all right
yeah next cuz I don't know what we
supposed to be looking at right
there yeah they definitely is on another
level not a overreaction them boys is
definitely on another
level not going to no Texas them bro
sorry to tell you that I'm staying
here hey give me
that over him yeah definitely got a
bunnies not overreaction hurdle one hand
it's crazy IM imagine if he would have
scored off of that that would have been
super tough
snagger hey give me that you ain't
catching me oh you thought you just want
to get me no
sir yeah that's
crazy
next yeah that's tough
not over reaction same thing happened to
me bro it's just a great catch there's
nothing you can do about
it great
position great position none that you
can do by look at the ref calling pass
interference but I don't get that but
y'all just be calling pass and do y'all
not be watching football or do y'all not
know how to play
football not passing fence but they
fighting hand
fights what we got
next
what the
hell let me see
this I want pay
attention
Pink Perfect that's something we try to
do one
time that's
good let not over rea action that's
perfect kick right where it's supposed
to
go I be intentional just get the hit off
somebody e to get
it next oh there we
go oh I seen this
yeah your hand BL the entire defense
definitely is not over
reaction one hand snag breaking get off
of me
touchdown yeah he embarass the whole
defense definitely snatch
snatch get off
me not over
reaction
[Music]
stupid is that a t
now I mean they recovered it still
he's slow as dirt oh but he definitely
fumble he def out bounce he try to lay
on
it def out of bounds yeah buddy just
took
it not overreaction I don't know what he
was doing and he got caught how you get
H
I
guess yeah I guess that goes
hard bro doing too much uh we missing
some yeah he definitely doing too much
yeah he
wiing bro whing what is he got on you
tripping yeah he
wiing not a reaction that boy is
definitely
whing I don't know if this gonna be the
game in the
year depends on who comes out and
play now they over reaction
though yeah everybody uh type in prayers
for Jordan Travis man prayers for JT man
hope my brother are doing good you know
I had to text him hope he just good man
blessings prayers my
brother all
right y'all got it right last week y'all
pick Georgia at number one college
football playoffs you know how that go
now we asking who gonna win between Ohio
State and
Michigan let's go let the votes be
yeah
5050 chat record three and
two we got we got who he got who he got
who he got who he got Ohio State Ohio
State losing I see a lot of people
saying Ohio State but voting for
Michigan how that
work how that
work oh we got
dang everybody coming in the chat to
vote for this what we got
man hey this game gonna be a tough game
Michigan got good DVS though
so mainly ought to stop that run because
Ohio State can definitely run the ball
but Ohio State got to stop that run too
because Michigan can run the ball
too they also can pass the ball too they
got a great quarterback they both got
good quarterbacks though it's going to
be a tough game for
sure y'all gotta say this game it's
gonna be a tough
game tough hard fault game
buddies all right
right all right guess Ohio State
everybody pick Ohio State all right bet
so chat say Ohio
State just leave me one option I gotta
go to Michigan but
hey okay Ohio State it is y'all play
Ohio State
hey every man for they
self all all right now it's time for
y'all to go ahead and ask questions
y'all can ask
questions I answer drop your questions
in the chat let your boy answer them all
right what we
asking favorite NFL team
49ers who you got winning I don't
know I like being coached by coach
Prime simple it's just like being
coached by any coach he's got a lot of
Wis though he got that gold jacket so
some of stuff you might not hear from
other coaches he says
so just gota follow what he
says who do I think win a championship I
do not
know Herz some Mahomes hey they're both
great quarterbacks I don't
care no I'm not transferring boy I'm
staying with the the Colorado
buffalos not going nowhere how Koney
doing good I'm guessing should be
straight last time I seen him he was
straight you going home for Thanksgiving
no we got a game on Saturday
Thanksgiving on Thursday doesn't make
sense and we have practice so no
favorite video game uh I be on fortnite
a lot 2K and Call of Duty those my
favorite three video games I be in them
all the time 24/7 how's your liver good
favorite fortnite skin I don't know man
I just be rocking anything I might hop
on Twitch after the season though we can
get some customs in some custom matches
in upload it to my gaming channel that's
what y'all want y'all just gota let me
know Xbox gamertag no sir I don't got a
Xbox got a
P5 keep gr keep grinding I will bro
appreciate it y number 12 my best uh
that was my best year
high school that was my
number so I was my I stayed with
it I got my first offer win number 12 so
I stick with
it CJ SC MVP yeah that boy is cooking
definitely going crazy right now I would
give it to him Thanksgiving Halloween to
Christmas Christmas Bo you know I love
them
gifts all the gifts I can
get
rank thank Thanksgiving
food ah I could do that for a video too
but I ain't going home for Thanksgiving
so I
can't all right let's get to the next
thing what we got next oh we next up we
got a blur you know how that go let's
get right into
it y'all gotta come with some next some
questions next time chat your headphones
fire appreciate it
bro headphones go crazy everybody that
FaceTiming when I be on the game like
bro them headphones is crazy
tough that's not a blur o
ah
ah no that hurt that's not a blur
though yeah my headphones just tough
sorry to tell
y'all cuz the color me what y'all come
on blur now that's a blur that's on his
head yes definitely blur on his
head BL oh oh oh I don't know that's not
a blur he Jing that too many times
nah it's not a blur come on man we got
to come with better blurs next
time jugle the ball that Ain no
blur good catch
though it's a good
catch hey hey
[Music]
hey blur that's two bodies you know how
I
get
know I get man I'm a little flexible so
my leg was just a little numm that's all
it
was how am I still walking just a little
nor just a little
Norm yeah but my mind I determined I say
yeah I'm going to get this sorry
y'all had to go take that from open them
boys Blue
Nation all right next up y know we got
play a video pause it and we guess the
outcome so let's get right into that
yeah that's
our that's supposed to guess that QB
score on bootleg
definitely wait this look like a jump
pass
see wait no that that bootleg is open
though yeah it was a bootleg I knew it I
knew it was a bootleg why did I pry I
was trying to see that receiver came out
it was defin I mean b it definitely
B just look like it was to
open
bro what happened in this play I
don't I don't know bro b i mean
a supposed to be a but it's B and B yeah
I'm I say
B nah no I said he
bro it's two B's
bro
yes sir I'm right you know
it bo
bo we got
next off the his
zank okay they got four receiver over
there it's a trick
play boy he look like he fumble
that receiver forming up ball at the
goal line receiver throw back to QB for
TD no thought receiver was going out
right
there
throw
nah it's no touchdown on so the receiver
did something
hey C chat saying C bro chat why y'all
lying's see bro
see
see he th it back to the quarterback bro
yo
bro see bro I know y was
c b it
is
bro you got to protect your hair bro I
don't care what y'all be talking about
bro Bunn bro a nothing wrong with a
bunnet bro you got to protect your
hair hey bro be yourself don't let
nobody talk down on you and make you
change
yourself you heit me here be costing too
much but I get it for the free cuz my
girl do
it nah bro ain't no bunny is cruel you
tripping you see my hair see how done
imagine if I a wear a bun it my hair
won't be looking like this right
now if I a wear a bun it my hair won't
be looking like this right now durx no
DX is not good for your hair bro she
just hurt your head in Ohio what is in
Ohio for me to do why would I be in
Ohio but yeah you know I wear a bunet
for my hair bro my hair could stay
good if you going to get it D matter
what it's treated
right so that's why about
it all right y'all Y know what time it
is is the end the end is near you know
what time it is man before we end you
know we back on the road to finish off
the season vers Utah
hey we just got to come out with a win
to end the season off good that's hey sh
week still got
fight so that's so we doing we got to go
there so we still got fight we ain't
going give up and let's prepare for next
season so let's go right there win and
do our job catch y'all next week we
ain't G to talk too much about the next
game we just going to go out there and
do what we got to do to come out with
this dub see y'all next week what I see
y next week yeah I don't know if I'll
see y next week but if I do see you
Monday it's your host Travis Hunter with
12 talks see you later see you next time
be safe bless up love peace
out appreciate
it all right see
you